first i wasn't telling anybody i was
going to food pantries and then i
decided that that was just
like keeping a secret makes things get
worse if i didn't have my job
i don't know what i would do it's
150 200 cars starting at 12 o'clock at
night
so by time three four o'clock in the
morning gets here
it's a it's a it's it's a it's an
ongoing thing with cars
until they close
everybody's just worried about their
next meal
because everybody can't work from home
and everybody doesn't have careers
where they can just operate on a
computer and still have their
income coming in somebody like me that's
a limousine driver
shuttle bus driver a bus boy
corn tortillas
these are the i don't know if those are
little turnips or radishes so i'm going
to check those out
later today half a dozen eggs
which is helpful so
those tomatoes i found at first i wasn't
telling anybody i was going to food
pantries and then i
decided that that was just
like keeping a secret makes things get
worse so and makes me feel worse about
myself and so
i decided that it was more important to
talk about it
like you know i have to pay my electric
bill and i have to go to the food pantry
oh right there you go have a great week
thank you so much oh you're welcome
what
i'm pretty sure if i if i didn't have my
job
i don't know what i would do i don't
know what i would do if i didn't have
hillside it would be very hard
it's it's really going to be hard to see
a future
you know unless they decide stimulus
or bail you out as if if it wasn't for
the people being able to have you to
come out to get
some food to put on the table
we'll be worse off no doubt
we will starve
this is what you call blessing right
here
you